I actually think that if we're going to
do pausing it might be easiest not to
dive into compilers straight away some
of you might want me to do but to
actually just take a simple very simple
subset of the English language and see
how we would pause that and if you look
up in a dictionary what is pausing mean
it says essentially one of the
definitions is breaking up sentence
structure into its component parts under
the direction of a grammar so the
grammar is the rules of your language
well I have drawn up here a language
involving furry dice and robots and
people men and women and cats and dogs
and they can bite they can stroke they
can whatever and I thought that little
grammar which I'll walk you through is
capable of generating between two and
three hundred sentences and they are all
valid English but there's no way it
captures the spirit of English the idea
that your sentences have
subject-verb-object is pretty universal
I think among what's called the
indo-european languages however
sometimes it's not always in the order
of subject verb objects although that's
common sometimes they get twisted
repeatedly in German where there's a
definite option to have the verb last in
this example I'm pointing to here I'm
using a notation that we did cover about
three or four years ago now we'll put
out a link
I think the episode was called angle
brackets and they invented a notation
that looks like this pointy brackets yes
back in the very late fifties and early
sixties people who wanted to write
compilers realized they had to write
down a formal specification of what were
the rules in their language and two
computer scientists actually won the
Turing award ACM Turing Award for their
notation and their development of a
grammar
for the language Algol 60 and it uses
angle brackets all over the place so
that was so-called backus-naur form
those are the two computer scientists
who developed it people really liked it
and I've used it here because it's
verbose enough to make some sense I'll
read it out to you what I'm saying up at
the top of the grammar using the angle
brackets for what's going to become
parts of a so-called parse tree a
sentence is defined as subject then a
verb then an object that's the most
common form of English sentence the
subject is the personal thing doing the
action the verb says what the action is
kicked bit stroked whatever the object
says what it is doing it to the man
kicked the robot and it's such a
powerful language you can have either
the or are definite or indefinite
article you can have the robot or a
robot you can have a choice of verbs
either bit kicked or stroked you're
gonna be very expressive in this
language your subject of the sentence
can either be dog cat man woman or robot
and finally the tailpiece the object
i've decided could either be any article
followed by a noun again like a dog the
robot bits a dog perfectly possible but
just to show that you can put in
shortcuts if you like and put bits of
structure in there that aren't pars
they're just a glob it you can put in I
have defined the phrase two furry dice
as being a valuable object just the
string two furry dice so the target
sentence that ultimately we're going to
try and construct from all of this is
the lower case robot stroked running out
of space here carry on on the line below
the robot stroked two furry dice we all
agree it makes sense is it possible
against that set of rules and how would
you go about showing that it was so by
possible you mean can we decode it can
we decode it can we assign everything to
be the right flavor of structural
component according to those rules now
you can either start with a string which
we've got here and start trying to group
things together and work upwards now we
all know about trees the root is at the
top we're computer scientists the root
is at the top the leaves are at the
bottom they're always upside down do we
start with and leaves and say oh the
robot stroked oh the robot sucking
looking sideways at the grammar I can
see there's a shortcut for the robot so
I'm gonna start coming from the string
upwards and see if I end up back at the
root of the tree or shall I start at the
root of the tree and say I must have a
subject then a verb done an object can I
see anything that could likely be the
start of a subject that's called coming
top-down so it's been there in computer
science ever since the dawn of computer
science the top-down approach versus the
bottom-up approach
there's no prizes for guessing that
functional languages like Haskell tend
by their very structure to favor the
top-down approach its Messier is the
bottom-up approach also trying to
indicate both okay but let's just this
just this once
let's go top down rather than bottom-up
if we're coming stop down it is telling
me is this grammar that I must have a
sub
then a verb then an object now for those
of you who are concerned with a
mechanistic s-- you can actually think
of these things if you're coming top
down as being pushed as targets that
you've got to satisfy on a stack which
we all know about stacks this one is not
building upwards and downwards it's
building from right to left so at the
top of my stack currently because I'm
coming top down I say my target my sub
target is sub I must find a sub but I
must keep half an eye on the target
string to say does it really match
if we cross refer now to this grammar
for inspiration we're trying to match a
subject if I look at the grammar over
there it tells me that a subject can
either be an article and a noun like
Vernon R with a noun like cat dog robot
or you can take a shortcut because it
tells you here that the subject just
could be the phrase the robot so let's
go for broke
looking at the input string and I see
the robot so let's take the shortcut
just to be devil's right I can say
straight away and then taking the
shortcut that subject can be the string
the robot that's good
now having satisfied soldier I poppies
off the top of my stack I've done that
next thing to match this sentence
you've got shell to match the verb well
we're going along the string we've coped
with the robot next word next valid leaf
word that has to match up with being a
verb I'm looking at stroke is stroke two
possibility look at verb what are the
possibilities for verb and I say bit
kicked or stroked great at you stroke
but once again if you can imagine the
stack I then pop that off the top of us
that we've done in the stack is
shrinking all we've got left to identify
is an object that matches that sentence
again I've pulled a fast one here in the
rules for object I said you can either
break it down into an article and now
just like the subject so nice having the
action done to it or you can take a
witty shortcut an aloud shortcut for an
object is what you might call an object
phrase and I put it in deliberately just
to make a point to furry dice wonderful
simple sparse going an object can be too
furry dice we declare success and we say
we have matched the robot strokes to
furry dice by going subject verb object
subject came down into being shortcut
the robot verb developed straight away
into being stroked object shortcut to
object phrase it's a very shallow tree
really but it's developed the target
sentence the robot stroke to let me dice
now the only thing you might say well
yes wonderful we've paused it but would
it have worked if the subject instead of
taken the robot shortcut could you have
done it with the article now option yes
you could
I could have basically come here let's
write our on suburb
yeah and yes right at the beginning
instead of taking the shortcut phrase
the robot I could have said ah but I'm
going to do it as subject can be an
article followed by a noun so the head
of the stack then or would be when we're
looking at the sentence and starting off
from the beginning again it's got to be
an article to start with article is that
order oh I'm looking at the string I see
that bingo
so article can be ver no problem pop
that off the stack what's the next thing
what to look for noun can noun B robots
which is next thing I'm looking at yes
robot is an option so I could have done
robot now the verb is as before
it's got to be stroked and stroked is
there and equally the object is as
before there's only one way to develop
the string to furry dice and that's to
take the declared chalk that does it for
you the reason for doing this rather
artificial example is to say oh dear
does this matter we have got a sentence
that makes perfect sense to us the robot
stroked two furry dice but you've drawn
two slightly different trees first time
you took a shortcut subject phrase just
for the robot next time you said ah but
we could also do it by breaking it down
further into other and a robot does that
matter in this particular case in
informal spoken English no it doesn't if
people understand you the fact that your
grammar is technically called ambiguous
so if you say to yourself what does
ambiguous mean it means there's more
than one parse tree this seems to
satisfy and give the final target phrase
does that matter in this case no does it
matter in general yes because you might
get very different effects under certain
circumstances what I think I'll show you
is a favorite one almost which is to
check your for function desk calculator
when you start typing things into a full
function so-called handy calculator
you're basically putting in shall we say
integer numbers that's simplify it but
the burning question is something like
this that if you type in eight star four
star two you may not think of it in
those terms but computer scientists
would say yes if you got the right
grammar rules that's an example of a
sentence in quotes you know that is a
what's it what might you call is a sort
of subsection of a long calculation that
you do on the right-hand side of your C
statement it's just eight times four
times two there's no problem mr. 8/4 of
32 to 32 or 64 but then you say ah but
we're into tree structures now how would
you parse that sentence given that
multiply can only multiply two things
it's time so are you going to arrange it
so that your overall expression groups
as eight times four done on the left
then you do the multiply by two which is
that tree structure so the question is
you've got a little bit of depth on your
tree structure here it's gone down a
level whereas finally you've got one up
at the top level do you want that sub
structure to be on the left or on the
right because it would be equally okay
as we've got things at the moment for
you to draw something that's got eight
here multiplied by here for two with a
multiplier between so have we got a
little bits of tree structure on the
left or on the right and does it matter
and you say no it doesn't matter we all
know that you can't complete the
expression until it's the left operand
is known and that involves forcing you
to do the multiply eight times four is
thirty-two find thirty-two what's the
other up around here is x - 32 to 64
equally over here 8 x 4 2 - 8 8 8 and 64
so you're doing it two different ways
but you're getting the same answer and
the reason that's ok
is that multiplied is well behaved
mathematicians will tell you it commutes
a times being is the same as B times F
or integers
however just look at the but ambiguity
okay two different paths trees and it
didn't matter for multiply just suppose
those multipliers weren't multiplies but
were divides does it then matter that
you do eight divided by four first in
this one you get you two and the
multiply is in a more positive add two
divided by two one
but look at this other possibility and
just mentally substitute devised for
multiplies eight divided by the result
of four divided by two well 4 divided by
2 is 2 8 divided by 2 is 4 two
completely different answers is it one
or is it four if you're panicking take
out your calculator now and check the
app just do 8 slash four slash two and
if the answer isn't one demand your
money back
here we see it then here is an example
of where ambiguity does lead to problems
because depending which tree you choose
you get a different answer so there we
are then we now know what a grammar is
we know that against a grammar you can
try and parse things like sentences but
sentences used in its widest sense it
could be a program statement from C and
just think of this eight times four
times two has been as a part of a phrase
on the right-hand side of an arithmetic
statement and grammar is the guiding
principle for the whole thing parallel
work in America that they didn't know
about had already got there ahead of
them in many ways I think some of the
mathematical logician friends said John
Peter are you aware that there's a man
called Chomsky in the USA he's a
linguistics man but very fair